if you were an intelligent alien
civilization oh boy
and you came about Earth
how how would you interact with it can
you put yourself in the mind of an alien
civilization because there seems to be
some parallels here
it is actually right it's like a
microcosm of we're very aggressive human
civilization is very aggressive so if we
were easily we get threatened easily
yeah
for stupid reasons because we start like
a American Military probably thinks it's
like the Chinese or the Russians
if we see any kind of flying objects it
gets very on edge I don't know I mean
because you know part of it is like you
just want to ask like that's the thing I
just want to ask questions yeah but you
know but you don't know the same
language yeah you're gonna get first of
all you send a boat of bananas you send
a boat of bananas you get shot
um I mean picture if aliens landed in
New York how long would it take for one
of them to get shot minutes if you're a
matter of minutes yeah that's because
it's New York and everywhere else look
where we are right now that's true it'd
be even worse here yeah uh make makes me
really makes me wonder what is the right
way to interact
with
intelligent life that's not like our own
I hope I I dream of In Our Lifetime we
would interact with
possibly Life on Mars or on one of the
moons of Jupiter or Saturn and like how
do you interact with that thing
well this is very technical biological
and chemical processes but also if
there's any kind of intelligence how do
you try to communicate with that
intelligence yes we're not talking about
like a cockroach we're talking about
like some something that's clearly like
doing things making things well
cockroach possibly how do you know the
difference between a Cocker like how do
you know we were just talking about
yeah we don't know we don't know we have
just like a race of like philosopher
cockroaches right chilling on the Rocks
well here on Earth we kind of there
seems to be a strong correlation between
size and intelligence like yes it seems
like the bigger things a bigger nervous
systems and brains and so they're
usually smarter but that doesn't I think
it's brain it's the ratio brain to body
sure because you have like crows yeah
that are up among the most intelligent
it's like the size of the brain to the
size of the body but there also could be
kinds of intelligence will work
completely no idea we're not
appreciating maybe cockroaches it's
survived the longest they're talking
[__] about us right now it's dumb humans
like dude
these rocks are so great a couple of
hundred years exactly
um did you ever you ever hear that Kurt
Vonnegut where the two space Travelers
get lost this this this really impacted
me as a kid because my dad was an
English teacher so he's always quoting
Dostoyevsky and uh and Kurt Vonnegut and
there's this there's two space Travelers
get like crash landed in a cave
and on the walls of the cave are the
harmoniums and these kite-shaped animals
and they feed off the vibrations of the
cave and that's all they do they don't
hurt each other they just do that and so
for like two years these Travelers are
stuck and they're trying to fix their
ship and one of them starts playing
music for the harmoniums and the
harmoniums love him for the music and
they all come around him and and he
plays this music for him and finally
they they fix the ship
and then the one guy is like all right
let's let's get out of here and the
other guy's like you know what I'm
staying
he goes I I found a place where I can do
good
I'm not hurting anybody and they love me
yeah I'm staying right here
yeah this whole ambition thing we got
going on always trying to build a bigger
boat bigger thing that might not be the
the ultimate
um
conclusion of a of a happy existence as
a civilization that's probably that's
one of the possibilities why we haven't
met the aliens yet at scale it's because
they're once you get good enough at
technology you realize that happiness
lies in a peaceful coexistence as
possible
so where do you stand on like aliens now
like there's a lot coming out about the
the pilots and the the things people
have been seeing and again like I kind
of come in and out of this stuff like
I'll be in the jungle for three months I
miss I miss a lot so like update me like
or or are we are we being contacted
right now like of course nobody knows
but I tend to believe my intuition says
there's aliens everywhere that
um there are even our galaxy
sure that's biggerly but I believe our
galaxy has
probably billions
hundreds of millions of planets with
life on it like bacteria type of life
sure and I believe there is
I don't know thousands of alien civil
intelligent aliens civilizations that
exist or have existed the problem is
there's a lot of time and it's very
difficult to contact each other
so to achieve
a kind of civilization that's able to
actually send out enough signal or
um radiate enough energy where we would
notice I think that's really tough
that said statistically speaking it
seems like that should have been
possible inside our galaxy or maybe
nearby and so
I suspect
that um
once an alien civilization is just many
orders of magnitude smarter than us
humans the way it would contact us
is going to be very difficult for us
humans to understand we're very
egocentric we want the message to be
sent as like a
in English
versus you know I think Consciousness
itself yeah emotion
um
thoughts
could be like fingertips
um could be words in the story that the
aliens are telling us
or the things that are just like a low
dimensional projection of a much higher
dimensional message that's being said by
aliens and it may be our striving to
create technology is to create the kind
of sensor that's actually able to hear
some of the message maybe that's what AI
is trying to do so I I think that
bridging that barrier of communication
between us and cockroaches
I think that's the biggest challenge
interesting like the messages are all
around us they're here
I I suspect that the the alien messages
are here the aliens are here we're just
too dumb to see it
so
first of all the imagining planets where
there are
like just picturing like a like a not a
silent Planet but just like a planet of
alternate life forms you know maybe it's
not something that's that we can
communicate and have a conversation with
but just like a planet of like
butterflies and centipedes and and weird
you know unfortunately bacteria for
billions of years it was uh bacteria as
a single cell prokaryotes and eukaryotes
but they're not they're boring but yeah
but animal animals of some sort in an
environment of some sort imagine that
would just be such an interesting
beautiful amazing thing and I'm sure
they're out on that I'm yeah the kind of
viruses they got going on
it's uh but they could also not be
biologically based they could be
different chemistry so you have to be
humbled to that too sure
but then you know depends on the day
like I think you caught me on that day
today an optimistic one
sometimes I I think that we're all we
this is all there is because you start
you ask that question the family Paradox
like why aren't they here
you can't imagine an advanced animal
civilization that would not be explorers
because we're explorers
why is that
depressing to you that the idea that
that let's just say you found out right
now that there isn't anything else let's
just say that
for for example sake that the Earth is
the earth and the universe is the
universe and it's sort of like the
backdrop of a video game
and it's just what's out there would
that be tremendously depressing to you I
think it's exciting for an engineer it's
probably exciting for an Explorer but I
would equate that to your going out
hiking for three days with one match
it kind of terrifies me that we only got
one match really
yeah really yeah one all you got is one
match
this no no hold on a second hold on a
second wait Paul wait wait a minute
you're going out
there's no more matches but this this is
the only match no we couldn't extinguish
the planet like there's not as far as we
know there's no there's no meteor coming
I'm saying like do you live in a so I'm
saying is that is is your worry then
that we need to have a backup plan yeah
really well there has so like what if we
do what if we do mess it up so bad
that uh we can't live here anymore well
there's different ways to mess it up
there's there's ways to mess it up to
make life really difficult uh
but there's nuclear war yes with the
further and further advancement of the
technology that can destroy destroy all
of Earth it just feels like that's going
to be exponentially growing yes it's
going to get worse and that I I it's uh
listen I'm I'm very optimistic
but it's a it's a heck of a Russian
Roulette we're playing okay so but I'm
still curious about your your intention
though or like where you're where your
your passion for this comes from are you
is your or maybe it's both but is it is
it is it the need to have a backup plan
for humans which which is which is
admirable for your intense love of
humanity and our Consciousness and love
and art and everything or is it also
just that the the raw fascination of
imagining what's out there
um because I just the way you said that
about like oh you caught me on a
positive day where I think it's
there was some there was something in
there that made me think that that you
need there to be uh yeah yeah there's
I think I'm the kind of person that sees
Beauty in everything but to me a
universe full of diverse life
is more beautiful than one where it's
just humans it's just the Earth life
interesting there's more Beauty I mean
uh I'm not egotistical about the
awesomeness of humans I like
if humans are not the smartest
in uh in our galaxy
are not even close to being the smartest
and that to me is
I don't know that that to me is exciting
about the possibility of what's oh the
universe can create
yes I'm with you on that that it's
wildly exciting to to like if we found
even if it was just a distant
inkling that we found out that there is
there is a planet that has life there's
no there's no communication coming from
but we know for a fact there's stuff
going on there we'll just change how we
think about our entire reality we know
now
and it could be to me I guess the little
inkling of a thing that is depressing if
all there is is Earth
and humans destroy it
then we're the coolest thing that the
Universe has ever created
it's over I'm interested to have this
conversation I'm really I'm really I'm
saying like I would be interested to
bring you to the Jungle yeah
um and and this I like now I'm also
wondering I'm wondering like what what
your Wilderness experience is because I
feel like for me
I'm so earth-centric to the to the point
where I'm like
we differ in that for me this is like
it's a curiosity I feel wonder and I
feel it's fun to talk about like what's
at the edge of space like you know
there's the conundrums of of space-time
and but but I'm so to me I'm like what
if what if the aliens are watching us or
what if the aliens aren't watching us
but what if the challenge here is we've
been put on on Earth as as the most
intellectually complex of these
creatures and and and we're being
observed to see how we manage it and
it's like yeah we haven't made a good
job of managing each other
you know before
um orianna went down the the Amazon I
mean they showed up and just sacked the
Incas I mean we do our history and we
don't have to tell you you just got back
but it's um
I just sometimes I wonder
you know what what the is is there a
grand narrative with with what we're
doing to Wildlife because it's like we
have all these other species and we're
we're struggling even here in this
conversation to sort of quantify like
you know
and I think that most people don't think
outside of the human framework
you know what I mean like just driving
around for me living outside of the
Jungle even just for a few weeks I get
you don't you don't you don't even think
about the fact that there's other
species around us we really don't day to
day you look at TV and you look at you
listen to the radio and it doesn't it's
not very consequential to the average
person living in a city that there are
these
you know Islands covered in walruses and
that there's rainforests filled with
birds and and frogs and all these things
happening and that you know the salmon
are contributing to our fresh water and
and that that life is literally given to
us and made possible by these ecological
systems to me
that's where like the whole you know
essence of my existence comes from and
so like
okay thank you for that reminder because
you're basically saying like the alien
civilizations you dream about are here
on Earth
those those those worlds are here
for me yeah yeah no I agree with you I
think I I agree with you and I think
that's actually the way I
uh think most of the time the you know I
I think I'm on mushrooms all the time
genetically somehow because when I go
out in nature it's just the the beauty
even of nothing you talk about the
Amazon man just basics of nature yeah
fill you fill me with awe and the other
thing that fills me with all
is our own mind like the the biology of
these things firing basically are not
our own mind but biology yeah of any
living organisms
because it's like an ecosystem they've
came these cells came together they
somehow functional they delegate they
mostly operate in a local way but they
uh
first of all it's just like you said
with the anacondas you start out as a
tiny snake and you become giant when
you're a tiny snake you're you're
praying for everything when you're a
giant snake you're a predator or you're
afraid to no one yeah and like just that
whole process same starting with a
single embryo single cell is a human
into the embryogenic process
constructing this giant human that's
able to have
limbs move about the world think about
things write books and so on just so
that that is incredibly beautiful and
all of that is here on Earth yes
um and so actually I was being sort of
poetic about aliens and so on I think I
can spend 99.99 in terms of uh filling
my mind with awe and Beauty just looking
down here on Earth for sure I agree with
you yeah and I'm and they shouldn't
cancel out like I think it's beautiful
that there's that there's people that
are fascinated and obsessed with looking
out into space and that will travel
there
um I mean just to me the the idea of I
mean I have a little piece of meteorite
at home that I hold and it does amazing
things to my mind because I'm like
everything I've ever touched is from
this Earth
holding this thing that's been places
that we can't even think about
and it blows my mind and I love it but
but when it comes to like intelligence
I think it's like
I'm I'm so concerned with the fact that
we're at this moment in history
and it's interesting to me that you know
we had the internet and now that with
the emergence of AI and more and more I
feel like we are starting to resemble
like an ant colony where there's more
and more connection and there's more and
more interaction globally between
everybody in the next 10 years we're
gonna have to decide are we gonna let
our ocean ecosystems just collapse are
we going to just take that three percent
of rainforest and just let them log the
[__] out of it until it's gone and it's
like we're gonna be in a very different
reality then then it's going to be very
dystopian future or
can we keep the good things about Earth
transcend that realize that we have
these incredible alien species around us
that are animals that we grew up with
that we wouldn't be here without that we
owe something to
and I feel like at that stage then
the the the outward look becomes
something else it's almost like we've
we've proven that if aliens came up to
us that's when I'd feel good
aliens would come up to us and they said
you know that Louis has the thing where
he goes God comes back and he goes what
did you do he goes to polar bears are
brown he's like I left food for you it's
like if the aliens came and were like
you know and they interviewed the
elephants and they said how are you
feeling and the elephants would be like
listen [__] these little primates yeah
you know what they've done to us and
it's like I mean you know I've seen
people break an elephant I've seen I've
seen I've seen it all with that stuff
and it's like if if anybody was to ask
them
they'd be screaming
and and so like to me
it's just you know I I have trouble
trouble looking out into space I have
trouble looking out into normal life as
a human because I'm so concerned with
trying to make sure that they're okay
because not enough people are doing that